let's define ourselves some sets so
let's say the set a is composed of the
numbers 1 3 5 7 and 18 let's say that
the set B the set let me do this in a
different color let's say that the set B
is composed of 1 7 and 18 and let's say
that the set C is composed of 18 7 1 and
19 now what I want to start thinking
about in this video is the notion of a
subset so the first question is is B a
subset of a and there you might say what
would a subset mean well you're a subset
if every member of your set is also a
member of the other set so we actually
can write that B B is a subset and this
is the notation right over here this is
a subset B is a subset of a B is a
subset so let me write that down B is
subset subset of a every element in B is
a member of a now we can go even further
we can say that B is a strict subset of
a because b is a subset of a but it does
not equal a which means that there are
things in a that are not in B so we
could even go further and we could say
that B is a strict or sometimes that a
proper subset of a and the way you do
that is you're essentially you can
almost imagine that this is kind of a
less than or equal sign and then you
kind of cross out the equal part of the
less than or equal sign so this means a
strict subset which means be everything
that is in B is a member of a but
everything that's in a is not a member
of B so let me write this this is B B is
a strict strict or proper proper subset
so for example we can write that a is a
subset of a in fact every set is a
subset of itself because every
of its members is a member of a we
cannot write we cannot write that a is a
strict subset of a this right over here
this right over here is false so let's
give us give ourselves a little bit more
practice can we write that B B is a
subset subset of C B is a subset of C
well let's see C contains one it
contains a seven it contains an 18 so
every member of B is indeed a member of
C so this right over here is true now
can we write that C is a subset can we
write that C is a subset subset of a can
we write C is a subset of a let's see a
every male element of C needs to be an A
so a has an 18 it has a 7 it has one but
it does not have a 19 so once again once
again this right over here is false now
we could have also added we could write
B as a subset of C or we could even
write that B is a strict strict subset
of C now the we could also reverse the
way we write this and then we're really
just talking about super sets so we
could reverse this notation and we could
say that a is a superset a superset of B
which and this is just another way of
saying that B is a subset of a but the
way you could think about it the way you
could think about this is a contains
every element that is in B and it might
contain more it might contain exactly
every element because this you can kind
of view this as you know you kind of
have the equal symbol there if you were
to view this as greater than or equal
there not a quite exactly the same thing
but we know already that we could also
write that a is a strict superset is a
strict superset of B which means that a
contains everything B has and then some
a is not equivalent to B so hopefully
this familiarizes you with the notions
of subsets and supersets subsets and
supersets is
subsets and supersets and strict subsets